Mối buổi sẽ diễn em được miếng gần ai,
vì thế nên thế này, để thế một buổi nữa,
chúng ta sẽ có tính buổi nữa để trí ở đây này.
Phá nguồn trong nó có sống mới bài tóan,
trở lại gặp 2 bài khó thôi,
nhưng mà sau đó thì thế là cấp lên,
cho kèm thành bài bài bài bài bài bài đi tìm,
người nằm này nữa thì các bạn có gọi đơn giết họ,
và các bạn nên vệnh trước của nằm trước,
và đặc biệt, và đồ không hiệm của tế hoặc nha bùa trở ở trong 1 trăm mài tóan chắc,
hay 2 bài, nhưng mà sau đó thì thế là người chỗ các bạn,
luôn cả một trong bài tóan chắc,
cho kèm với 2 bài bài, để cho kèm có thể,
và hồi làm kèm bố thiền hồi,
cái kênh tên điệu kênh nằm,
và tất cả các bạn tập đấy thì thế sẽ trở ở tòan buồn.
Giữa số buổi học,